tapotez
une norme
encore une norme de plus mais rassurez
vous c'est pas une norme comme les
autres le poète comme vous demandez
aussi ce que c'est n'est ce pas
simplement une organisation régionale
qui est promotrice du développement par
la qualité bio est les a hébergés par la
communauté du pacifique que vous
connaissez sans doute pour la plupart
d'entre vous donc l'ex cps donc il
s'appelle maintenant tout simplement
comme ça j'ai la chance la chance de
faire partie de ce groupe weight comme
depuis huit années et depuis 4,2 de son
conseil d'administration
alors qu'est ce qu'il a fait de bons ce
poète comme depuis huit ans mais d'abord
il a élaboré une norme qui est celle la
première donc l'agriculture biologique
au cnm et bien sûr on l'a appliqué sur
le terrain surtout du côté de l'ouest du
pacifique pour divers raisons un petit
peu géopolitique
ça changera peut-être quand la polynésie
française intégrale forum mais on en
reparlera donc des choses qui ont bougé
du côté de l'ouest du pacifique est
aussi maintenant on en est à donc cette
fameuse norme bio tourism qui a est en
cours de finalisation d'élaboration mais
elle est pratiquement opérationnel
c'est financé par cubain par les
organisations vous voyez apparaître le
logo et vous allez me dire aussi non
descôteaux ismail ans il y en existe
beaucoup de par le monde
effectivement il existe beaucoup mais il
s'agit là de faire progresser
l'écotourisme vers le bio l'idée l'idée
aussi c'est que bien entendu on associe
ce ce bio au tourisme pour de la
cohésion de développement durable et du
potentiel identitaire et pour mener à
quoi à une valorisation commune
environnemental et culturel
nos valeurs à défendre
pour ça il faut effectivement donc un
verre un référentiel une norme et bien
sûr sa mise en application
alors qu'est-ce que maintenant que la
qualité bio que j'ai commencé à évoquer
alors dans le monde
c'est là prenez une progression
inexorable pardon que vous avez pu déjà
constatée sur les marchés avec des
produits tels que aussi maintenant à la
cosmétique
voilà on a largement dépassé
l'agriculture tels que le textile aussi
et maintenant donc les services qui sont
aussi certifié bio l'océanie des
concepts se rajoute donc une norme et
évolutive
le concept qui se rajoutent pour faire
court celui du naturel et du culturel
certifié bien entendu et puis s'est
rajouté aussi bien sur cette notion de
care qui en français vous l'avez compris
et celle du soin de la tension de la
bienveillance une notion qu'on retrouve
non seulement bio bien sûr mais déjà
dans le tourisme et à travers bien sûr
le premier de ces critères dans
l'océanie la culture et les traditions
qui sont des repères et des piliers
déquilibre sociétaux
on a aussi comme 2e pilier l'éthique est
l'équité qui aussi constituent des
piliers de développement durable bien
sûr l'écologie et la biodiversité et qui
sont la clé des équilibres de la vie sur
terre
enfin la santé et la durabilité pas de
possibilité de développement durable
santé publique bien entendu c'est
rajouter une notion à travers tout celle
que je viens de présenter qui est celle
de l'adaptation aux changements
climatiques et qui déjà figure dans la
norme aux siennes and agriculture
biologique pour maintenant les défis qui
concerne l'application de la norme
elle-même il s'agit bien entendu les
coûts de certification les procédures
qui peuvent être problématiques aussi
des revendications frauduleuses qui
peuvent aussi poser quelques problèmes
les demandes de produits locaux qui
peuvent être inadapté
on va voir pourquoi un approvisionnement
précaire aussi qui peut être aussi
problématique est aussi la progression
de la législation on a au fenua une une
loi de pays qui encadrent le bio qui est
la nôtre pays 2011 1 et qui se limite
malheureusement aux produits
alimentaires alors qu'il y a beaucoup de
demandes pour les fleurs important dans
le tourisme n'est ce pas les huiles
traditionnels les semences les services
maintenant
des exemples alors déjà envoyé une série
de l'opérateur qui sont efficaces dans
le pacifique et qui défendent la culture
une culture qui façonne l'environnement
et inversement
un environnement qui façonnent la
culture on parle maintenant de paysage
culturel
une notion qui parlent réellement à nos
visiteurs
quant à la faisabilité et les parcs l'a
déjà testé cette faisabilité
si del parque travaille maintenant dans
le domaine du conseil et de la formation
ça a été un jardin botanique de 86 à
2006 sur 5 hectares donc toutes les
productions et est certifié les
productions dans le dans sa restauration
pour son bar de jus de fruit et pour sa
quinzaine de produits agroalimentaires
un parc énergisé par personnel radieux
épanouie et par à 100% d'énergies
renouvelables
les opérateurs qui sont concernés il
s'appuie ici
les log le logo de mise en valeur de la
qualité bio donc vous l'avez aperçu est
ce ces logos donc et une version
française une version anglaise donc
comme le propose en tant qu fanion
régional fagnes original tour de la
cohésion toujours plus de cohésion
toujours plus forte
on peut imaginer concrètement est
logiquement d écoute nos intra pacifique
avec des trajets associés natif
inactivité un seul billet la diversité
dans la découverte
il s'agit des mutualisations de
l'attractivité pour des actes et
visiteurs qui ramènent chez eux et
valeurs fortes dans le monde attend de
loin les différents types de
certification qui sont envisagées
actuellement mais d'autres options sont
en en cours d'étude
il s'agit d'abord de la certification
total avec bien sûr dans le cas de
structures hôtelières complète qui va
totalement certifiés ou simplement la
restauration ou alors simplement une
partie du menu ou des plats de cette
restauration
pour les prochaines étapes le poète
comme travail sur le système de garantie
donc l'application des procédures
il ya deux choses différentes donc les
normes alors leur système de contrôle
système d'application s'agit d'un ce
qu'on appelle le système de garantie
donc est en cours de d'élaboration voilà
ma roue